let's talk about Cuba we have the newest
development in Donald Trump's ongoing
quest to undo anything good that former
President Barack Obama accomplished
you'll remember that two years ago
President Obama loosened up the travel
and trade restrictions between Cuba and
the u.s. because let's face it the
decades and decades of fighting
communism through the Cuban embargo was
mostly just punishing average Cubans and
a potential American tourists and
American businesses Without Really
defeating communism through that embargo
and it made no sense to continue
including the fact that it was
completely hypocritical for the u.s. to
maintain it so a majority of Americans
and about half of Cuban Americans like
what President Obama did but Donald
Trump is going to be reversing many of
those things very complex things as
Trump likes to say that President Obama
did here's a little bit of video for you
on my recent trip overseas I said the
United States is adopting a principle
Grille ISM rooted in our values shared
interests and common sense I also said
countries should take greater
responsibility for creating stability in
their own regions it's hard to think of
a policy that makes less sense then the
prior administration's terrible and
misguided deal with a Castro regime
[Applause]
yeah I like how Trump says it's hard to
think of a worse policy than what Obama
did with Cuba
I thought the Paris agreement was the
worst policy according to Donald Trump
I thought the Iran deal was the worst
policy according to Donald Trump in any
case Trump wants to make it more
difficult for Americans to travel to
Cuba for tourism he wants them more
closely monitor the purposes of people's
trips to the island nation Americans
will have to fill out forms when they
come back to the US explaining what they
did why they did it only things like
charitable and educational visits will
be allowed and those will be more
strictly enforced and Donald Trump plans
to make it illegal for American
companies to do business with companies
owned by the Cuban government that is
hilarious
because Trump explored and arguably
violated trade law when he explored
doing business in Cuba he ended up going
down there and not personally right but
sending sending representatives down
there to explore doing business there
they spent sixty eight thousand dollars
in 1998 to explore whether they wanted
to do business there they potentially
skirted the illegality by running the
money through some consulting agency or
something like that and Trump ultimately
decided not to do business in Cuba not
because it would have violated the
embargo but because he decided it wasn't
a good business opportunity so as always
with Trump it's bad policy wrapped in a
double standard served on a plate
alongside hypocrisy yeah and on the
campaign trail he was a lot more
moderate on this issue it seems that
since he's taken this Marco Rubio style
approach which is that we have to get
everything and they have to get nothing
yeah make a deal with them and you know
that could include having Cuba no longer
punish dissidents or or you know open up
their their Free Press and all that
stuff but it's not like this thing can
really be renegotiated so easily now it
can't and Trump also as part of this
once to prevent Cuban refugees from who
reach us Shores from having immigration
advantages which has been a longtime
policy of the US Trump talks about how
it's all about helping Cubans now of
course supposedly the entire embargo was
to help Cubans get out of communism but
that didn't exactly work now it's all
about
helping Cubans how are you helping
Cubans by not giving them those
advantages in the immigration system I'm
not arguing for or against those
advantages but it can't really be argued
that you're helping Cubans by getting
rid of those advantages and
fundamentally this is about appeasing
Cuban Republicans right if you look at
the entire Latino electorate it is very
very liberal and I've spoken about my
family in Argentina you've basically got
the left side of the family and the very
left side of the family and that really
you're talking about intra left debates
in many Latin and South American
countries one of the few groups of
Latino voters that more regularly is
represented in the Republican Party is
Cuban Americans who oftentimes as a sort
of knee-jerk opposition to Cuban
communism decide to go Republican in the
US because that's what feels most
opposed to that that's who Trump is
pandering to with this and of course a
lot of Cuban Americans have settled in
Miami and in Florida at large and that's
a state that he would have to win if
he's going to secure re-election in 2020
it seems not to even be thinking about
Trump's reelection at this point but
it's no foregone conclusion that he
wouldn't be reelected he might be
impeached and/or resigned in shame or he
might end up serving eight years I mean
we really just have no idea at this
point and anything in between is
obviously possible as well